روسيا تتهم أوكرانيا بامتلاك قنبلة قذرة ،
هل لديك قنبلة قذرة ، هل
تحضر قنبلة قذرة ،
هذا سؤال أصبح شيئًا
من المزاح وإجابتي مباشرة ، نحن
لا نستعد لأننا لا نعمل
على قنبلة قذرة
لدى أوكرانيا  دعا
مفتشي الوكالة الدولية للطاقة الذرية للحضور إلى
هنا عندما يحين موعد وصولهم إلى
أين سيذهبون ومتى تتوقع
نتائجهم ،
نحن ندعم تمامًا
زيارات مهمة iaea ونحن
في انتظارهم نحن في انتظارهم  لزيارة
جميع المنشآت
النووية وقد حددت روسيا موقعين أه
أكاديمية العلوم هنا في كييف
ومنشأة تعدين في وسط أوكرانيا ، ما
مدى أهمية قيام مفتشي الوكالة الدولية للطاقة
الذرية بسرعة كبيرة بتوضيح أوكرانيا من
كل هذه المزاعم الروسية التي لا أساس لها من الصحة
فور وصولها.  ستكون الأشياء الأفضل